With Avengers: Infinity War, the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is heading towards a conflict that's
been building for nearly a decade.
Thanos has been on a collision course with
the rest of the heroes since 2012's Avengers,
and he's finally taking center stage in a
battle for the Infinity Stones.
The war will unite an entire universe of superheroes,
but it'll also likely have lethal consequences.
Given the stakes involved and the Mad Titan's
status as the ultimate bad guy of the Marvel
movies, the question isn't if one of the heroes
won't make it out alive, but which one.
"I hope they remember you."
Let's take a look at the cast of Infinity
War to come up with our best betting odds
on which heroes might not make it to the closing
credits.
Watch out for potential spoilers as we figure
out who's going to meet their maker… and
we don't mean Stan lee.
"Are you Tony Stank?"
Black Panther
The Marvel Cinematic Universe has doled out
more than its share of jaw-dropping surprises
over the last decade, and the studio's braintrust
has proven itself more than willing to take
bold creative risks with the franchise's storytelling.
But Marvel Studios also has to consider its
bottom line, and since Black Panther just
became one of the highest-grossing superhero
movies of all time, there's no way the executives
are going to let him get away that easily.
Forget about his Vibranium stockpile, pulling
in that much money at the theater is what
really makes T'Challa bulletproof.
There's just no way Wakanda's king isn't one
of the heroes left standing once Infinity
War is over.
Odds: 1.239 billion (and counting) to 1
Spider-Man
Also far too promising for dismantlement right
now is Spider-Man.
Granted, Peter Parker is going to be completely
outmatched against Thanos and seems to be
primed to suffer some serious punishment in
the movie.
But with a second Spider-Man: Homecoming movie
due in theaters next year, the chances of
him being truly taken out by Thanos seem slim.
He's just way too new and too popular to meet
his end just yet.
"You're that spider guy on YouTube, right?"
"Call me Spider-Man!"
"Okay, Spider-Man! Do a Flip!"
"Yeaaaahh!"
Odds: 100 to 1
Gamora
She's the deadliest woman in the galaxy, and
she's got a major grudge against Thanos, who
basically stole her from her home planet and
tortured her adopted sister.
Gamora might have been Thanos' favorite daughter
growing up, but she doesn't seem to have much
love for the Mad Titan now.
It seems more likely that she'd be the one
to take down Thanos than that he'd ever get
to lay his purple hands on her.
After all, she learned from him.
Odds: 75 to 1
Black Widow
Fans have been clamoring for Black Widow to
get a solo movie since she first kicked her
way onto the screen in Iron Man 2, so getting
rid of her before we actually get to see her
stand alone seems like a catastrophically
bad idea.
That said, Natasha Romanoff's fate during
the Infinity War Saga could go either way.
If it's her backstory that people really want
to see, it doesn't matter much that she survives
in the current timeline, right?
With Hulk, Captain America, and the Black
Panther at her side, though, she's probably
still got a good shot of hanging in there
this time.
Odds: 50 to 1
Hulk
On one level, Hulk is arguably the easiest
character to get rid of in Infinity War.
He hasn't had a solo movie since 2008's Incredible
Hulk, and he's kind of a liability for the
Avengers anyway.
With Marvel seeming pretty uninterested in
giving the Hulk a solo spotlight, there's
a strong possibility that his part in the
franchise might be coming to an end.
It's also worth noting that Mark Ruffalo revealed
that the plan has been to give the Hulk an
arc that would begin in Thor: Ragnarok and
continue through the two Infinity War movies.
In Ragnarok, Bruce became the Hulk for years
at a time, which allowed the Green Guy to
run the show without Banner's knowledge or
approval.
It's easy to see how that loss of control
might not work out so well for him, then,
isn't it?
Odds: 20 to 1
Thor
Thor: Ragnarok was funny, but it also put
Thor through the wringer.
His hammer was shattered, he lost an eye,
and his homeland of Asgard was destroyed,
leaving him exiled in outer space.
If the plan is for things to keep getting
worse for the Odinson, then there's really
not a whole lot left do with him but plant
him under a tombstone.
But with so much coming down on him in his
own movie, Thor seems to be gaining strength.
He's now able to channel his supernatural
gifts, and he's expected to get a new hammer
in Infinity War, called the Stormbreaker.
So, it seems just as likely that the God of
Thunder's luck will turn around in the film
as it does that he'll keep getting trounced
by baddies.
Or himself.
"Cuz that's what..."
Odds: 15 to 1
Drax
Of all the Guardians of the Galaxy, Drax seems
like he might be the most likely choice for
the chopping block.
In the comics, his entire reason for living
is to execute Thanos.
Since the movie version tends to launch himself
into battle without thinking of any consequences,
his fast fury could lead to a toe-to-toe fight
with the deadliest being the Marvel Universe
has to offer.
If that is in fact what happens, it's pretty
hard to imagine Drax coming out as the winner.
At the same time, Dave Bautista's performance
in the Guardians movies have made him a fan
favorite, so the question is whether the shock
value of having him take one for the team
is enough to outweigh the benefits of keeping
him around.
Odds: 12 to 1
Hawkeye
Even before he was curiously absent from the
film's character-heavy poster, Hawkeye hasn't
been the most obvious priority for Marvel
Studios, and his arc reflects that.
He's retired, gotten bored enough to join
Captain America's illegal strike force, and
been imprisoned as a war criminal by Iron
Man.
Those are all pretty good signs that the Marvel
Cinematic Universe doesn't have much left
to do with the archer beyond giving him a
noble death to let everyone else know the
stakes in the war against Thanos.
Let's be real for a second, though: if they
did kill off Hawkeye in Infinity War, would
you actually even notice?
Odds: 10 to 1
Star-Lord
Another hero who seems unlikely to die at
the hands of the Mad Titan is Peter Quill.
"What the?"
After all, he's already survived a couple
of cosmic threats before, so what's one more?
Plus, Chris Pratt's comedic chops have set
the tone that the Guardians movies are built
on, and that seems to be carrying through
to Infinity War as well.
"I think it's good, except it sucks.
So, let me do the plan."
On the other hand, Star-Lord's death would
be a huge shock, which might mean it'd be
worth it just for the sake of keeping audiences
on their toes.
Besides, he's half Living Planet, and as we
all saw in Guardians 2, it takes more than
a couple of blaster bolts to the head to take
one of them out permanently.
Nobody ever said these characters have to
stay dead to make it onto Thanos' kill count
for this film.
Odds: 10 to 1
Doctor Strange
As the Sorcerer Supreme, Doctor Strange is
the only one who's faced the kind of celestial
threat Thanos represents, taking on Dormammu
by himself and coming away with a victory.
With that kind of win on his record, it seems
likely that Strange's formal introduction
to the Avengers could be the thing that tips
odds in their favor.
"Who's laughing now, a------?"
But his future in the MCU is questionable
at the moment, since even Benedict Cumberbatch
doesn't seem to know whether Doctor Strange
2 is gonna actually happen.
The filmmakers did already set up Baron Mordo
as a villain for his next outing, but we'll
have to wait and see whether that pays off,
or if the mystic meets his end in the Infinity
War instead.
Odds: 8 to 1
Vision
He saved the day in Age of Ultron, but since
then, the Vision's had a pretty hard time
fitting into his role as an Avenger.
In Civil War, he couldn't even stop Hawkeye
and Scarlet Witch from walking out of a room,
and a misfired laser beam wound up permanently
injuring War Machine, one of his own teammates.
With that kind of track record, it's tough
to imagine him lasting long in a fight against
Thanos.
Moreover, Vision has one of the Infinity Stones
mounted on his forehead, and from the film's
previews, it looks like Thanos' minion Corvus
Glaive might just get to him before it's all
said and done.
Suffice it to say, things aren't looking good
for the Avengers' resident synthezoid.
Odds: 5 to 1
Nebula
It's no secret that Infinity War is drawing
pretty heavily from the events of 1991's Infinity
Gauntlet storyline, and in that story, Thanos
keeps Nebula suspended just on the verge of
death as a form of torture to amuse himself.
The twist is that Nebula is ultimately able
to get control of the Infinity Stones herself,
which sets into motion Thanos' defeat.
Since Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2 spent
so much time patching up Nebula's relationship
with Gamora — and establishing that Thanos
is no stranger to mutilating her just for
kicks — having Thanos target his renegade
daughter would be an easy way to show moviegoers
how ruthless he can be.
Or she could end up being one of the people
who helps take him down in the end, as it
was written.
We'll have to wait and see.
Odds: 5 to 1
Captain America
Steve Rogers is easily the most beloved of
the Avengers, so if the film's producers really
want to hit the audiences with a gut punch,
killing off Captain America would do it.
What better way to reunite the Avengers after
the events of Civil War than having them rally
around his heroic sacrifice?
The previews certainly seem to be setting
the tone for a tough fight between Cap and
Thanos, and Chris Evans himself has confirmed
that he intends to retire from blockbuster
movies in favor of smaller films.
It hardly seems like a coincidence that Steve
Rogers has not one, but two characters that
could take up his shield if he falls in battle:
Falcon and Bucky Barnes.
Evans has mentioned that he's still set to
appear in the movie that comes after Infinity
War, but there's nothing that says that appearance
won't be in a flashback… or a coffin.
Odds: 3 to 1
Iron Man (Tony Stark)
We don't know for sure, of course, but it
looks like Tony Stark is not going survive
this movie.
"Wow."
It might actually be the only logical conclusion
to a character arc that's been building since
2008.
Over the past few movies, Tony's fears about
the changing world, and his efforts to get
ahead of the disasters that come from a world
full of superheroes and villains have gone
increasingly off the rails.
His attempt to create artificial intelligence
unleashed Ultron and resulted in the complete
destruction of Sokovia, which in turn led
directly to the Avengers themselves being
destroyed as a team during the events of Civil
War.
Even his most recent protege, Peter Parker,
was defined by his choice to reject the path
that Tony took as Iron Man.
With a conflict that's bigger and more far-reaching
than anything he's dealt with before, the
consequences are going to be just as huge
— and for Tony, that likely means a heroic
sacrifice.
There's a certain poetry to it.
Iron Man was the movie that kicked off the
MCU in 2008, and what better way to mark the
10th anniversary of the cinematic universe
than by killing off its founding character?
It'd be bittersweet, of course, but it'd be
the best farewell Iron Man could hope for
to sacrifice himself for the sake of the planet
and the universe at large.
"Tell me his name again."
Odds: 3 to 2.
In other words, rest in peace, Iron Man.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!